foreign
[Music]
I'm Julia and I'm a product manager for
vertex Ai and I'm joined by my colleague
Mark who's the group product manager for
vertex AI extensions
hi everyone we're excited to join you
today we're introducing a new Cloud
platform our team is developing to build
extensions which help large language
models access real-time data and
real-world actions
large language models are powerful
but they're frozen in time after
training this means their knowledge
becomes stale and they can't dynamically
call external services
our new platform will change that by
allowing developers to create Enterprise
extensions that securely connect llms to
the real world
Mark will give you an overview of the
platform and how to create an extension
and then I'll share some early examples
of how developers can use our platform
to create new an llm driven applications
hi everyone
so imagine that you're working at a
company and you have a new product
launch coming up for a retail store and
you go to an AI chat bot and you ask can
you tell me more about the coverage for
this new retail store
you're likely to get a response like
this
I apologize but as an AI language model
I don't have real-time data and my
knowledge only goes up to my training
date therefore I cannot provide specific
information about events beyond that
date
I bet many of you seen texts like this
LMS can be very useful but they have
significant limitations
first they are frozen in time they don't
have access to new data after their
final training date this leads to stale
or inaccurate responses this also means
that they can't access internal company
specific data after training Foundation
models are usually trained on publicly
available data but many organizations
have large troves of internal data they
don't like models to securely access
finally they can't interact with the
world they can't access common
interfaces like apis which limits their
ability to take action for users
extensions also known as plugins help
address these problems by connecting LMS
to apis effectively connecting them to
the real world and the first example
here a search for press coverage on the
company's latest launch triggers a
real-time search to summarize the latest
articles
in the second example an employee wants
help buying electronic components to
build a new product that triggers the
supply chain extension to search
inventory in real time confirm the
component is available show the cost and
complete the purchase in the app
in the third example the employee asked
the company's deadline on benefits
enrollment the company's private
extension connects the llm to internal
knowledge bases and gives the employee a
grounded actionable answer
we see a world where LMS and apis are
combined to build sophisticated
extension powered applications this
includes digital assistance that can
create entire documents spreadsheets and
programs search engines that can provide
highly personalized responses grounded
in an Enterprise's context and automated
workflows that can streamline many tasks
in areas like data science and cyber
security
despite the promise of extensions they
have a number of challenges today
first developers lack effective tools to
create test and deploy extensions in
Enterprise environments we've talked
with a number of developers that have
created their own tools for tasks like
extension debugging and evaluation but
they would rather focus on work specific
to their use cases
second model output from extensions
often not accurate enough models too
often choose the wrong extension or the
wrong output format reducing their
usefulness and making it harder to chain
extensions together to solve complex
tasks
third extensions can access sensitive
data and actions creating new risks
Enterprises need robust controls for
security privacy and compliance
that's why we're thrilled to announce
vertex AI extensions a Google Cloud
platform to create Enterprise extensions
and extension powered applications
vertex extensions will enable
Enterprises to build extensions with
Google Cloud's granular controls for
data access residency transparency
auditing and compliance with internal
policies it will access Google's latest
foundational models that have been
trained on extension use cases it will
also integrate with the best of cloud
services such as bigquery and vertex AI
search to build fully featured
applications
we see vertex extension as a core
component of a larger extension
ecosystem that includes Enterprises
employees developers and end user
professionals and consumers we
categorize the benefits of extensions
into two main categories internal use
cases of making employees more
productive by connecting llms to private
data and actions and external use cases
by extending your products and services
into AI surfaces outside your walls
let's dive into how you create an
extension there are four steps first
select an API that you want an llm to
access if you want to create a new API
check out apogee Cloud's API Management
Service which is building tools to
easily generate apis and extensions
second create two extension files a
manifest that defines the extension's
metadata like its name description and
authentication and an API specification
that defines which methods the LM can
access
third test debug and publisher extension
using vertex's developer tools and
finally deploy the extension in an
application like a chat bot or an
automated workflow
vertex extensions makes it easy to
create and manage extensions you'll be
able to create extensions through our
API or the cloud console and link to
assets like logos and policies and cloud
storage our API spec format is based on
the open source open AF format and is
compatible with chat CPT plugins to
improve portability between ecosystems
I'll now hand it off to Julia who will
tell you more about her extension
developer tools and examples of
extension powered applications
awesome
so I'm super excited to show a little
bit more about how you can use these
various tools to not just create
different extensions but also to browse
and use extensions
with the platform you can build your own
extensions using your apis as Mark just
described
you could also use pre-built Googled
extensions for popular Google cloud
services like bigquery alloy DB vertex
AI search and code interpreter
you could also use partner extensions
for a variety of different tasks such as
data retrieval with data stacks mongodb
and redis or you can deploy your Lang
chain code through vertex AI extensions
in the gallery you can browse discover
and test these different extensions
enabling developers to get started
quickly
yeah
so now you've created that extension but
how do you make it useful
you want to combine extensions and the
associated llms at the application layer
to cover different use cases llms rely
on their reasoning to decide if and when
an extension should be called
this creates an agent operating in a
runtime
vertex AI extensions enables two
different types of application runtimes
a reasoning application runtime that is
managed by Google ensuring that the
right extension is called and that the
output format is controlled
and a customizable application runtime
that builds on open source Frameworks
like langchain deployed the rec directly
through vertex AI extensions
these two options support different
levels of customization
support and controls
but as those of you well versed in
machine learning know creating and
building is only part of the journey
evaluating performance is critical to
production grade applications
so for this having the tools to create
data sets and run detailed evaluations
is crucial
with vertex AI extensions you'll soon be
able to leverage a handful of your own
example prompts to create testing data
sets
using those data sets you can then run
experiments to understand where issues
in the system arise
and to collect examples to support
relevant extension execution
these tools are designed to help you
understand your extension-based
applications and how they're going to
perform
understanding potential issues enables
your teams to take actions to configure
and optimize your agents
with vertex AI extensions prompt tooling
you'll soon be able to test and optimize
your extension manifest and API
specification
with llm configurations you'll be able
to test different models with your
extensions to ensure that you're
choosing the optimal combination
the goal is to give you the tools to
ensure that you have confidence in your
extension-based applications
now you've heard a lot about the
platform and you're probably thinking
that the possibilities tend to seem
endless of what you can do with
extensions and I tend to agree and
that's why I'd like to focus on two
concrete examples of how vertex AI
extensions can be implemented in real
world workflows
retrieval augmented generation and
custom Enterprise applications for data
analysis
retrieval augmented generation is an
industry term that essentially means
using data from an outside source to
help the llm generate the correct
response
extensions can be incredibly powerful
for this especially when they're
combined with your company's information
whether you're a retailer looking to
generate a targeted ad campaign on the
fly leveraging a consumer's loyalty
information
or a security company monitoring and
classifying threats using extensions
will help you drive factuality and
personalize the responses that are that
are shown to your users
on the other hand vertex AI extensions
can Surface tools like code interpreter
wherever they're most useful to you and
your users
so that you can analyze and understand
and visualize different data sets often
without even generating a single line of
code
now
I'd like to explore some of those real
world use cases in some early customer
examples but I'm going to give you all
the caveat the internet hasn't been
working very well this morning so I am
doing all of the demos off my phone
internet so pardon if they're a little
bit slower than originally planned and
bear with me a little bit
all right so the really exciting demo
and story I get to tell today is
actually together with the Formula E
team
at the end of July Formula E put their
data their New Gen beta race car the
industry's fastest lightest and most
powerful and Efficient Electric car and
Racers Jake Hughes from McLaren and
Lucas Degrassi from Mahindra racing to
the test in an attempt to set a new
Guinness world record for the fastest
speed achieved by a vehicle indoors
the two Racers drove the Jen better car
a revolutionary Formula E electric race
car on an indoor track in London and
over three attempts Hughes was actually
able to break the world record
but not only is this a testament to the
technological innovations of Formula E
and their gen better car vertex AI on
gcp actually provided the analysis of
each of the drivers runs
using the vertex platform Hughes and
Degrassi were able to interpret
real-time Telemetry data to understand
speed power and grip
this gave them the ability to interact
and Converse in natural language to
fine-tune their different approaches
now let's check out the system that they
were actually able to interact with and
go to the demo please
yep all right
so
so let's speak with let me put my racing
hat on here and let's speak with Jen
better
first off you can think of you can think
about eraser just having finished one of
their specific laps so I'm actually
going to switch over to the driver mode
here one moment
and I would like to understand maybe a
little bit more about what my speed and
G-Force was exiting the last left corner
What's Happening Here in the background
is actually the sensoric information
from the car is being streamed via Pub
sub into bigquery to make it available
to the vertex AI llms and as you can see
my speed was 59.88 and G-Force was 1.271
exiting the last left corner
now I might want to ask
what was my maximum G-Force
again we're making a call out to
bigquery in the background to ensure
that we're generating and the relevant
information for the specific drivers so
that they can adjust their various
attempts
and finally given that this is an
electric race car
I might want to ask what was my battery
capacity when I reached the top speed
this is particularly interesting as a as
a driver of electric car because you
want to be ensuring that you're using as
much of that battery as possible
so what you can see here is that we're
essentially making the information
available to the drivers in natural
language so that they can adjust their
various attempts across the system and
to give you a little bit of a peek
behind the scenes I'll actually take you
into the bigquery Telemetry data so you
can see the response from the last
question as you can see the speed tends
to get faster and then we end up with
7.7 which is exactly what we were told
the battery capacity was at the top
speed
now Formula E was really really excited
about this and they didn't just want to
give the drivers a new experience they
also wanted to give their fans a new
experience and so they created what we
know as the fan bot were they hooked up
vertex AI search in the background
filled it with some of their information
about Formula E about their history and
about the Gen beta car to create a new
interactive experience for their fans
so
let's talk to the fanbot and learn a
little bit more about the race cars
as I just shared the system is reaching
out in the background to Enterprise
search to learn a little bit more about
the car and in this case it's gen betta
is a Next Generation formula ecar it's
still under development but it's already
broken the indoor land speed record it
can has a top speed of 200 miles per
hour which is pretty interesting and
it's faster than the previous
generations of Formula E cars
now I'm also curious what is the g-force
that you actually put on your drivers
this is interesting because I just want
to learn a little bit more about what
kind of stress the body is under when
you're in this race car and so as you
can see the driver is put under a
g-force of 2.5 that's pretty cool
but now I'd like to test its creative
skills and I'd like to understand a
little bit more about what it's like to
be inside the world's fastest car
as you can see it's an incredible
feeling to be inside the world's fastest
car
it's a real Rush of adrenaline
especially when you're able to go fast
in such a confined space and boy am I
glad that the demo played along
especially when I'm streaming things on
my phone so I'm definitely feeling that
Rush of adrenaline right now as well
all right if we could go back to the
slides I'd love to give you all a little
bit of a sense of what's going on under
the hood
now that we've had this chance to speak
with Jen better
the initial Focus here was on creating
two different Bots
one that would enable the racer to
interact with the data on bigquery
and the other bot that would enable the
fans to interact based on vertex AI
search
for the first version
the Google Cloud CE team a huge shout
out to this team by the way working
together with Formula E put together a
demo structure using langchain and the
various components across the gcp stack
while the team was able to get things up
and running really quickly the biggest
challenge turned out to be deploying the
code on a gke cluster as well as the
complex prompt management needed for
retrieval accuracy
and that's where vertex AI extensions
comes in in the second version which you
actually just saw running today
the team was able to quickly and easily
click to deploy their launching code and
llm configurations through the
extensions platform to get an HTTP
endpoint embedded in the UI that you saw
this helped simplify the architecture
and ultimately significantly cut down on
the develop on the development time
as Formula E looks for ways to integrate
this experience into their next season
we're building together towards of E3
bringing together the components as part
of the vertex AI extensions platform to
create a common experience for the racer
and fan backed by production grade
security privacy and traceability on gcp
as well as supported by vertex managed
reasoning to drive consistency
now that we've got a better
understanding of how a customer could
deploy Langton code on vertex AI
extensions let's explore some additional
retrieval augmented generation use cases
vertex AI extensions doesn't need to be
in the classical chat interface that we
see everywhere today
customers like Manhattan and gitlab are
looking to leverage the vertex platform
to create their own workflows
Manhattan Associates a recognized leader
in supply chain technology is looking to
leverage vertex AI extensions
to optimize Warehouse operations
they believe generative AI has the power
to provide unparalleled automated
insights
for supply chain managers and
professionals
but only with the ability to ingest
their internal apis to pass data at
production or at scale and in production
they hope to use vertex AI extensions to
balance labor assignments
based on real-time utilization open work
and deadlines to automate supply chain
processes
as someone who got into the into Supply
Chain management during covid-19 I'm
particularly excited about this about
this use case
gitlab on the other hand hopes to
leverage vertex AI extensions to
increase the accuracy of their latest
feature supporting developers in
resolving vulnerabilities
here they'd like to have the llm have
access to security remediation knowledge
as well as potentially the user-specific
code base so that they can provide more
tailored accurate and personalized
information to the user and get them on
their way quickly
we're super excited about all of these
different use cases and have many more
of them to share with you but
as we transition retrieval augmented
generation
is not just the only thing that becomes
easier and more powerful with vertex AI
I'm particularly excited to share how
data understanding
analysis and visualization can be
transformed leveraging the databases
where you have your data in conjunction
with the power of co-generation and
execution
many Industries have huge amounts of
data that they've collected over the
years after five years at Google I've
seen all this data but it's largely been
left to specialized data science
functions and machine learning Engineers
to make use of it because of the complex
processes that are associated as you can
see on the left or on the right of the
slide
leveraging vertex AI extensions the goal
is to unlock all of these different use
cases and allow those that don't
necessarily know how to code
to actually interact with the data in
natural language across any kind of
industry to answer questions like
what was the average fuel economy of my
fleet over the last six months
or in the farming space what nutrient
mix did I provide to my wheat Fields
this year
or in the retail industry how much of a
specific product at a specific location
was sold in the last 12 months
these and many more questions are ones
that we'd like to enable customers to
get answers to and not just in the
classical data science and machine
learning functions
that's why with vertex AI extensions
code interpreter you can implement the
ability to analyze and visualize data
wherever it's most useful to you and
your users
whether that's a chat interface an IDE
or a different UI you can make it useful
to your users in the way that's useful
to you
by connecting your data extensions you
can then safely access the internet and
an Enterprise secure
privacy compliant and scalable way
now let's jump into a quick example
and since it's hard to surface the power
of an API you'll see some of these
visualizations and mocks to help outline
some of the concepts the answers and the
code generated are however generated
from the underlying tools and we will
actually jump in just to get a sense for
what's going on under the hood
to illustrate this example I'm
particularly excited to actually be
using a real data set from my family who
are Avid beekeepers and this is data
that we've collected over the years from
our different beehives
so let's assume that a developer has
created this chat interface for me using
vertex AI extensions code interpreter
here you can allow your users to upload
a file as I'm going to do
or to connect to a database instance
like bigquery
here I'm choosing to Simply upload a CSV
with the data about my beehives
next I'd want to add prompt information
about the data so I probably don't have
a great sense of what data is actually
in this spreadsheet that I've uploaded
and so I'd like to understand what all
the different headers are that I can be
asking about
so I've asked
um what the different headers are and as
you can see it correctly generates the
code to understand those headers showing
me hey there's wait some time
temperature
Etc available to me
now
I'd like to understand how the weight of
the hive is changing over time so that I
can figure out when I should harvest the
honey
and to ensure that the bees have enough
honey to survive over the winter
so I'll ask code interpreter how the
weight changed over time
as you can see from this natural
language query it's generated the code
to visualize that image now let's take a
quick jump into the code and actually
look at what the code that was generated
if you could switch to the demo
perfect
so as you can see here
we imported various libraries first off
we then read the data from the CSV file
did some filtering extracted some
information and then sorted by the date
and the time
plotted the weight over time and then
set the title and access labels so that
I would know what's going on in the
chart and ultimately showed that plot to
us
if we go back to the slides
this image is great but there is one
problem with it there are two pretty
significant outliers that makes it hard
for me to actually see the chart the the
course of the the data over the graph
and so I'd like to ask code interpreter
to remove these two outliers
so I'll ask since there are outliers can
you remove them
great this is a much better picture I
can see the weight over time much more
clearly and let's again jump into the
code
so if we could switch to the demo
there we go
so here you can see
that it's added to critical pieces one
calculate the upper and lower bounds for
the outliers and then two filter the
data within those upper and lower bounds
if we go back to the demo
uh back to the slides excuse me
you can see this uh this looks great and
it definitely looks like it's time to
harvest some of that honey
um as you can see I actually do we do
actually have bees and this is our own
honey so super excited to be able to use
this data to show you this use case
now as you can see vertex AI extensions
is designed to enable these experiences
and many more we're super excited to
allow our developers to create build
evaluate and optimize their llm and llm
powered extension applications in the
places where they need the most
but I have to say that this wouldn't be
possible without the support of the
Fantastic Team that is behind Mark and
myself and so this is a quick shout out
to them thank you all so much for your
hard work and super excited to keep
building on this platform to explore the
various use cases together with our
customers and for that we'd love for you
to stay in the loop to share your use
case with us and to do so make sure you
sign up on that link
and then make sure you're signed up for
the vertex AI trusted tester program
um which also your gcp sales
representative should be able to help
you with if you do have any questions
thank you very much thank you all so
much
[Applause]
[Music]